vamos con el problema número 41 dice
sara hizo dos velas con forma de prismas
rectangulares rectos esto básicamente es
que tiene en forma de caja en donde los
lados son rectángulos y esos lados son
perpendiculares a los lados adyacentes
vale
ahorita hacemos el dibujo dice la
primera vela tiene altura 15 centímetros
largo 8 centímetros y ancho 8
centímetros
entonces más o menos es algo como así
esta es la primera vela
es la primera vela que nos dicen que
tiene altura 15 largo 8 y ancho 8 ok
la segunda vela es 5 centímetros más
alta pero tiene la misma longitud y
ancho entonces si a 5 centímetros más
alta tiene 20 de altura
20 de altura es aislado quede un poco
chueco tiene 8 de largo y 8 de ancho 8
de ancho entonces ahí tenemos nuestras
dos velas que quedaron bien bonitas
bueno le quedaron las hará bien bonitas
la pregunta es qué tanta será más se
necesitó para hacer la vela alta
entonces básicamente nos están
preguntando por la diferencia de volumen
de esta vela y esta vela de acá pero 20
es un número muy grande y 15 también
entonces encontrar estos volúmenes es
mucho así que para ahorrarnos cuentas
para encontrar la diferencia lo que
vamos a hacer es el siguiente truco esta
vela la vamos a sobreponer en esta de
acá
de esta forma aquí adentro nos queda una
pequeña vela de altura 15 centímetros y
lo que sobra arriba es una vela más
pequeña todavía de altura 15 centímetros
largo 8 centímetros y ancho 8
centímetros
entonces justo lo que estamos agregando
de volumen es el volumen de esta pequeña
vela de aquí y ese volumen es 5 por 8 40
por 8 320 entonces estamos agregando 320
centímetros
cúbicos de cera esa es la respuesta
muy bien vamos a pasar al problema
número 42 este problema dice dos ángulos
de un triángulo tienen medidas 55 grados
y 65 grados cuál de las siguientes
opciones no puede ser la medida de algún
ángulo exterior ángulo exterior del
triángulo vamos a platicar un poco de
ángulos exteriores voy a pintar por aquí
un triángulo pero voy a prolongar sus
lados van entonces ahí están los
vértices entonces los segmentos
simplemente los estoy extendiendo a un
ángulo como estos a un ángulo normalito
se le conoce como ángulo interior o como
ángulo interno del triángulo al ángulo
suplementario que corresponde
corresponde a considerar el ángulo entre
este lado y la prolongación de éste se
le conoce como ángulo externo este de
aquí es el ángulo externo o el ángulo
exterior observa que este ángulo este
ángulo mide exactamente lo mismo que
éste de acá porque son opuestos por el
vértice esta es una forma de verlo o
bien porque ambos son suplementarios a
este ángulo interno de aquí pero como
estos 2000
cuando hablamos de ángulos exteriores
nada más pensamos en uno en cada vértice
entonces en un triángulo tenemos este
ángulo exterior este ángulo exterior y
este ángulo exterior nada más tenemos
tres hay otros pero algunos se repiten
vale entonces solo es uno por vértice
bueno después de platicar de esto vamos
a ver qué nos dice nos dice dos ángulos
de un triángulo tienen medidas 55 grados
y 65 grados entonces cuál se ve más
pequeño este este es de 55 grados y este
es de 65 grados
y nos preguntan cuál de las siguientes
no puede ser la medida de algún ángulo
exterior bueno este ángulo exterior ya
lo podemos calcular este también son los
suplementos de estos dos nos faltaría
este de acá necesitamos este ángulo
interior vamos a llamarle x pero ya
sabemos que x con 55 con 65 debe sumar
180 grados
entonces x más cuanto 55 con 65 120 x
120 grados debe ser igual a 180 grados y
por lo tanto x es igual a 60 grados va x
es igual a 60 grados entonces con esto
ya tenemos toda la información para
encontrarlos
los exteriores los voy a marcar con otro
color
uno es el suplemento de 60 grados o sea
120 grados
y en ese color es muy parecido pero
bueno confía en que es diferente el de
acá es el suplemento de 65 180 menos 65
y eso es igual a 115 grados 115 grados
115 y 65 es 180 y el de acá de 180 menos
55 que es 125 125 grados entonces 115
120 y 125 si son ángulos exteriores pero
130 no es entonces la respuesta es de
130 muy bien vamos a pasar al problema
número 43 esto está emocionante dice
dice este color la suma de los ángulos
internos de un polígono es la misma que
la suma de sus ángulos exteriores o
externos qué tipo de polígono es aquí
vamos a utilizar una propiedad bien
bonita que la voy a contar ahorita no la
vamos a demostrar a lo mejor después
haga un vídeo pero lo que yo digo es que
no importa qué polígono tengamos si
tomamos los ángulos externos y los
sumamos entonces eso no siempre siempre
nos va a dar igual
160 grados por ejemplo en el problema
anterior teníamos 115 125 y 120 me
parece 120 si mira 115 125 es 140 perdón
240 y 120 es 360 entonces en ese
polígono raro en un triángulo con
ángulos bien feos nos quedó 360 es una
buena señal de que se cumple lo que yo
digo pero eso también se cumple se
cumple en otros polígonos aunque no
tengan tres lados por ejemplo intentemos
con un rectángulo en un rectángulo los
ángulos exteriores serían este este este
acuérdate que sólo podemos tomar uno por
vértice y este de acá pero son cuatro de
90 grados y aquí también nos queda 360
grados entonces eso está muy mágico es
algo que siempre se cumple y que tal vez
después demostraremos en otro vídeo pero
utilizando eso podemos reformular esta
pregunta nos dicen que la suma de los
ángulos interiores de un polígono es la
misma que la suma de sus ángulos
exteriores pero la de los ángulos
exteriores siempre es 360
es la suma de los ángulos internos de
360 grados
entonces qué tipo de polígonos tienen
suma de ángulos internos iguales a 360
grados pues justo los cuadriláteros como
este de aquí y una forma de probarlo es
tomar un cuadrilátero arbitrario creo
que ya habíamos platicado de eso pero lo
volvemos a decir lo dividimos en dos
triángulos
cada uno de estos triángulos coopera con
180 grados a los ángulos del
cuadrilátero ciento ochenta 180 entonces
el cuadrilátero tiene suma de ángulos
igual a 360 grados entonces la respuesta
es a los cuadriláteros muy bien ahora
pasemos al problema 44 vamos vamos a muy
buen ritmo nos preguntan cuánto es la
medida del ángulo x de este de acá va
aquí hay dos formas de calcular la
medida de este ángulo x una es más o
menos la tradicional y lenta y la otra
es la forma rápida vamos a hacer la
forma tradicional para que veamos de
dónde sale la rápida la tradicional
sería ponerle a este ángulo y a este el
suplemento de x le ponemos utilizamos
que la suma aquí adentro del triángulo
es 360 entonces che
y más 60 grados más 25 grados es igual a
ciento ochenta 180 grados
entonces yemas 85 grados 85 grados es
igual a 180 grados y aquí tenemos que es
igual a 95 grados y a partir de ahí
podemos calcular x porque simplemente es
el suplemento de g entonces x es igual a
180 grados menos 95 grados entonces x es
igual a 85 grados esa fue la forma lenta
y hasta eso no es tan lenta la hicimos
como en 20 segundos pero bueno ahí te va
la forma rápida la forma rápida es darse
cuenta que con x es 180 grados porque
son suplementarios 180 grados entonces x
tiene que ser lo mismo que 60 más 25
porque ye más 60 más 25 180 y más x es
180 entonces x es igual a 60 grados más
25 grados o sea x es igual a 85 grados
entonces ese es un buen truco aquí mide
85 grados para encontrar un ángulo extra
basta sumar los dos ángulos opuestos los
que están en los otros dos vértices
entonces nos quedó 85 grados que es la
respuesta sé muy bien vamos al problema
45 este truco de arriba es es muy útil
te recomiendo mucho pues no aprenderte
lo pero al menos y recordar como se
deduce pero bueno problema 45 si la
medida del ángulo exterior de un
polígono regular polígono regular quiere
decir que sus que todos sus lados y
todos sus ángulos son iguales entonces
el ángulo exterior es 120 grados cuántos
lados tiene este polígono ok entonces
vamos a jugar un poco con lo que nos
dicen ahí voy a tomar este uno de los
lados prolongados y voy a dibujar el
ángulo exterior
el ángulo exterior que nos dice que es
de 120 grados bueno si cada ángulo
exterior es de 120 grados entonces
entonces el ángulo interior como es el
suplemento mide 60 grados entonces
tenemos un polígono regular en el cual
todos los ángulos miden 60 grados bueno
pues que polígono tiene que ser ese pues
bueno debe ser un triángulo equilátero
el triángulo equilátero es el único
polígono regular en el cual todos todos
los ángulos miden 60 grados los internos
y por lo tanto los externos miden 120
grados entonces ese polígono debe tener
tres lados a lo mejor esto es un poco
informal pero puedes dar otra
demostración con lo que te conté de que
la suma de los ángulos externos siempre
es 360 grados cada ángulo externo es 120
imagínate que el polígono tiene n lados
entonces la suma de los ángulos externos
es n por 120 y eso debe de ser igual a
360 grados
de esta forma n es igual a 3 el polígono
tiene tres lados muy bien vamos a
dejarle hasta aquí en el siguiente vídeo
seguimos resolviendo
más problemas de este examen de
geometría de california